something i've been talking about for
certainly as long as donald trump has
been on the scene
actively involved in politics is the
rise of authoritarianism
the the risk of tyranny that we're
running
by allowing these people in power
along with authoritarianism is also
white supremacy and white nationalism
and just
outright racism
and chief the chief purveyor in the
united states right now of this kind of
rhetoric and what makes it most
dangerous is because he dresses up in a
suit and goes on fox news every single
night and has the most popular
uh cable news show in the history of
cable news
tucker carlson well this last week
tucker carlson has been in hungary
giving victor orban who is a a wild
authoritarian in the mold of donald
trump
steve bannon has called victor orban
trump
before trump was trump something like
that
and i want to play a little audio or
video and audio of a speech that tucker
carlson is giving in hungary
knowing that this speech is not for
people in budapest this this speech is
for people back home this speech is for
americans to hear and he is signaling
something
let's take a look looking at these
buildings which move me not simply
because they're old
and some have bullet holes
which in my view are a very useful
reminder
i wish i lived in a city full of bullet
holes in the building
we're going to stop it right there and
the reason we're going to stop it right
there because this is laughable
this is the same man
who whined and complained about having
to cower in his house while protesters
protested outside
and he is in fear
whining
yet i wish i lived in a town where there
were bullet holes and buildings
as he romanticizes this
disgusting because every morning you
look at them and you think to yourself
it could be really bad
because it's been really bad there's a
lot at stake
make wise sober long-term decisions or
else you could wind up with more bullet
holes
it's true
it's true
it's true
it's true
tough guy strong man tucker carlson
never served one single minute
in the military in uniform has never put
his life in harm's way has never put his
life in danger
for any cause
and he stands there hugging himself
talking about how he wishes he lived in
the city with bullet holes in the
buildings
if i would level
and i could spend all day
leveling
very accurate accusations against the
american foreign policy establishment
but the main one would be
that they have no sense of how bad
things can get
and it's this is the bad side of the
upside of america america is an
optimistic country always has been came
from all around the world showed up in
this
mostly untouched continent with the most
fertile farmland in the world
and an ocean to separate us from the
lunatics
and it gave us the feeling that anything
is possible and everything has been
possible and i will never stop being
grateful for that or proud of it
but the downside to that the flip side
the obverse the other side of the coin
as you say in hungary
is that americans have no sense of how
bad things can get
that it actually could be a lot worse
our physical isolation cuts us off from
the history of the rest of the world
there's not a passion to study what
happened before in a place that you're
building a new right right
yeah so we don't have a sense of that so
i love your bullet holes let me just say
i'm probably the only visitor to your
nation who's complimented your
small arms and artillery scars
but here's what i like more about the
landscape of hungary a few soviet
remnants notwithstanding it's pretty
it is pretty the buildings are pretty
the architecture uplifts
architectural uh
critic
tucker carlson so listen
what tucker carlson i believe is doing
here is romanticizing
uh the bullets in the building
in the wake in the direct aftermath of
an attempted overthrow of the united
states government a violent insurrection
that took the lives
of americans
an attempted overturning of a free and
fair election tucker carlson sits here
on foreign soil uh under the protection
of an authoritarian goon named victor
orban
and says these things criticizes the
united states foreign policy it has been
practice for presidents
to to to tread lightly even even foreign
dignitaries you don't criticize your
country while
away
even when obama made what conservatives
call the apology tour he did not do that
they criticized anything that they could
perceive as a criticism of the united
states even when there wasn't one
and the script has flipped now we have
tucker carlson
doing that very thing
and being roundly applauded by it
by conservatives
and doing this romanticizing signaling
to the insurrectionists while
denying that an insurrection took place
we all witnessed with our eyes what took
place what happened
with horror
if you are a reasonable person you
witnessed it
and now we're being told the sky is
green
not blue
that's not what happened
this is calculated
when we're talking about sleep we always
hear about how much sleep people get but
often neglected in the conversation is
the quality of that sleep which is just
as important and science shows that
lowering your body temperature during
sleep can help you be more rested and
achieve better sleep and that's where
our sponsor chili sleep comes in chili
sleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to help you
improve your sleep comes in two
varieties the uhler sleep system and the
cube sleep system that's what i have on
my bed both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make your bed as cold as 55
degrees i choose 60.
you can make it as hot as 115 degrees if
that's your thing
i don't feel hot anymore at night no
more sweating i'm sleeping better and i
love it i also have the chili sleep
chili blanket which helps keep me cool
on top as well they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video